at kyle
jolie o
who has the most legitimate chance
shireen
to win the nfc east a question i posed
to you while you have a cowboys jersey
hanging over your shoulder
does it matter mike that would be my
question i mean these are four teams
with three wins each and i meant to look
up what the record was somebody
mentioned it yesterday their record was
outside the division but let's just say
it's not very good probably going to be
the worst in nfl history they can't win
outside the division but the cowboys did
do that yesterday and because they did
that and looking at their schedule i
think they can win most of the games
left on their schedule this is the team
i expected to see the cowboys this year
obviously with a different quarterback
but andy dalton looked good and they
played they have played really well in
the last two games lost to pittsburgh
and lost game in a close game when they
didn't have andy dalton so i'm going to
say the cowboys just based on their
schedule you know washington is the key
game obviously on thanksgiving that's
for first place if they can win that one
every team they're going to be favored
or right in right there with the other
teams including baltimore which you
would have said a few weeks ago was
going to be a heavy favorite over the
cowboys
rocketing around somewhere in my brain
is the number 226 and 1 the nfc east
record outside the division going into
last week if that's true and there's a
very good chance it's not they've
doubled their wins to 4 26 and 1 with
washington beating cincinnati and dallas
beating minnesota so they're on their
way and look i'm going to give in to
recency bias here because when you only
have three wins each for the entire
season winning yesterday means something
and i think whoever wins on thursday
night is going to have a shine about
them and they're going to become
the consensus favorites to keep it up
over the final five weeks of the season
at leapers 500 how do you evaluate drew
lock this early into his career he
hasn't even started a full season worth
of games but he seems to have regressed
why does vic fangio have this job will
denver ever improve without no let me
start there shireen because here's the
problem in denver there are two problems
the first problem is john elway
has not done a good job of hiring
coaches or finding quarterbacks peyton
manning fell into his lap that where
both hall of fame quarterbacks thing
helped the connection established back
in 2012 but elway has not been good at
hiring coaches and finding quarterbacks
he stays in his job though because we
don't know who the next owner of the
broncos will be and one thing i pointed
out over the weekend that got some
traction locally but we need to be
paying attention to it nationally the
nfl is going to insist that one person
eventually have full power over that
franchise and it's going to be hard to
get all of the bowling children on the
same page to give one of their siblings
full power
they're not going to sign off
potentially they may have to sell the
team and i think until there is one
owner whoever it is we're going to
continue to have this process of lather
rinse repeat coach quarterback coach
quarterback john elway always there
and until another peyton manning comes
along this team is going to continue to
struggle
yeah it's almost like elway needs to see
that the quarterback has succeeded
elsewhere to have him come to denver and
be successful he can't draft him he
can't sign them and and drew lot
injuries and turnovers have just plugged
him over two years and when you look at
his passer rating and and where he is i
mean he's ahead of darnold sam darnold
so he has not been good this year he was
much better last season when he ended
the season but he had all those injuries
early that that kept him out
and now they are where they are again
going is he the quarterback of the
future and i think there's still a huge
question there with drew locke
yeah absolutely i had a lot of faith in
him but you have to stay healthy and he
hasn't and that's rule number one lamar
jackson has stayed healthy but he hasn't
been effective matt evonne asks given
how lamar jackson has periodically
struggled this year should the ravens
wait to extend his contract until after
the 2021 season or should they resign
him
this offseason look it all depends on
what they think of him shireen but it
would be a great opportunity to buy low
if they decide to approach remember he
has no agent which makes it easier
frankly to sign him than if he did have
an agent do it now while he's kind of
softened up than if he's riding a huge
season and may want more so it all
depends on how they view him as a
long-term option but they may be that
the one good thing if this season ends
up being a disaster they may be able to
resign him to a second contract for a
lot less
yeah that's the key thing mike how do
they feel about him i mean he looks so
good last year but even the passing
numbers weren't great he looked good
because he did things on the fly and
made plays with his feet and outside the
pocket and he's not doing those same
things this season he's still good with
his feet but he's not doing it in the
passing game this is a team that is
terrible passing the football and if
they don't get any better you have to
wonder how they truly feel about him is
he their quarterback moving forward
think about to joe flacco right they
gave him the big deal and it turned out
that he wasn't the guy that they thought
it was in the super bowl year he did it
the one year but that appeared to be an
aberration and maybe last year was an
aberration for lamar jackson too
yeah i think unless they can get him to
a great deal after this season you wait
and see what he does in 2021 all right
tonight the tampa bay buccaneers seven
and three hosting the rams six and three
but the bucks are one in two and easily
could be oh and three in prime time
bruce aryan's move practices tonight
this week there were some comments from
tom brady on friday that if you read
between the lines kind of like hey it's
on us as professional football players
to show up and play wherever and
whenever it doesn't matter that it's at
night we have to be ready to go period
will they be ready to go tonight shireen
well they better be ready to go because
i tell you what mike we had a question
we didn't get to on friday from the pft
pm posse and that question was who do
you think's the most underrated team in
the league and i think it's the los
angeles rams they are now number one in
total defense this defense is really
really good and we might as well just go
ahead and give that defensive player of
the ward to aaron donald and maybe
rename it in his honor too this is a
good defense and i think 48's the over
under take the under
yeah and how do you put pressure on tom
brady when it comes around the edge he
is very adept at moving forward quickly
there was a moment earlier this year
where it was almost a madden glitch how
quickly he moved forward when the pocket
was starting to collapse around the
outside but when you can bring the heat
up the middle that's when you can beat
tom brady he starts looking down at the
pass rush instead of down the field and
if aaron donald is wreaking havoc it's
going to be a long night for him in the
pocket i think the rams are going to win
i think they're going to win which
probably means that the buccaneers will
shireen who do you have tonight rams
yeah 300.
we probably just jinx the rams
well look and who knows this year and i
like that i don't like the fact that
we're expected to know what we're doing
because the reality is nobody knows and
that's when football is at its most
exciting nobody really knows that's why
they play the games they'll be playing
that game tonight in tampa bay
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports